[Applause]
patience is not a virtue
it is a weapon
[Music]
what's your wow rabbit
and you can see how these two super
grand masters made their way to the
final
hikaru nakamura beat levon panzolia then
edged out paramag sulu the top seed
in a boat game video guzrati has been
unscathed in the knockout beating alexey
roshini and then sweeping chakra
momojarov a bit of a surprise there mama
jarov
is a superstar but in the first game it
was getting to a position
towards the end game and well it looks
like
his tactics were sharper and then game
two as well in the time scramble it was
vidit who
looked like the powerful player that he
is and now he gets to face
as his reward hikaru nakamura for first
place in this knockout
both these two players stellar
ambassadors of the game of chess been
streaming a ton lately
made it on youtube echo on twitch and we
are just
making sure that the players are set up
and
i'll be getting the word on who gets
white in the first game remember it is a
two game
mini match of three minute plus one
second increment and
um looks like hikaru
is taking the white pieces if i'm not
mistaken so
hopefully these games take off soon and
we'll get to the chess
because you know me i'm always excited
for some
awesome speed chess great games to
commentate on
and well that it is just
looking to upset if you will another
super grandmaster
back to back so
you know it's hard to say in these uh
online chess events because vidin is a
powerhouse himself
but mama jarv in terms of least
over-the-board chess has the higher of
two
ratings and uh i was wrong nick hegar
has
black to start with so he gets black in
the first game
and so vidit will try to
prove the first move advantage here try
to take an initiative
you do not want to lose with the white
piece as we saw
you know we've seen what happens in
those cases you lose the white and you
somehow win with black not so easy
so forbid it you want to make the most
of
this in the opening game and for hikaru
well
you're kind of chilling we saw his
approach against para maxudo two draws
are okay with him because he is the
favorite
in the bullet
so we are going to have the games begin
right now
here we are so bit it y pieces plays d4
i saw him do the same against mama jarv
and will we get a king's indian no we
will not we will get
maybe a nim zone let's see how pita
continues here knight c3
typical bishop b4 after that no we see
knight f3 and d5 so we have the qgd
and we're going to get a catalan here we
go the bishop on the long diagonal
please take me on c4 that's
what has been asked and answered sure
you asked me to i will
so this bishop on g2 would love to
remove that bishop on c6 out of the way
but the problem is not easy to do that
you're not going to accomplish that
and this is the line i believe where
black takes an f3 and plays c6
so you take on f3 the bishop takes back
you play c6 and you claim that you have
a brick wall on the queen side here it
is exactly the sequence
and opposite color bishops white has
slightly more space but black has great
control over this b4 square
so that's the good news for black
control the b4 square no
targets to exploit but white just has
more space and
considering how quickly vit has been
playing this i feel like
maybe he has a little something up his
sleeve here because
black generally speaking shuffles around
a bit it doesn't really do much of
anything
you know if you play you can't play c5
that opens up the bishop you can think
about playing e5
but that has ramifications that you'll
have to deal with as well
so hikaru
i think we'll put a work on d8 maybe f
to d8 keep this rook on a8
he plays e5 okay i thought d5 now is the
move
because takes bishop takes and what
ideally you get
is if this black knight takes you on d5
you end up putting your own knight on
the light square and this bishop on d6
can't attack you so that's exactly what
we're seeing
maybe maybe there was a potential for
knight c3 first but
instead it takes back on d5 that was the
first one i said bishop can go back to
g2
and now the light square bishop is
better than knight so that's the problem
for black in these seven positions
it's not that white is much better but
why is a little pull
no matter the trades that we get if you
take on
c three minute night gets there i have a
slight pull thanks to the quality of my
bishop on g2
and now if i go knight d5 this could be
a slightly better
bishop of opposite color intense queen
and rook's middle game because the
problem on f7
is greater than any problem that white
has but black is still holding in all
these lines
and you have to try knight d5 though and
there are the sirens
i know there they go um
it's not for any players chances here
looks pretty
fine so far hey car looking like he's
having to time his life cracking up
i don't know what that's about
so a car is having a blast
and vidit seems to be really
laser focused on the center of the board
here and i guess that's what it was
about he decides to trade
one pair of rooks and this rook would
love to get to c6 and start trying to
get in the position but bishop c5 now
says
nope no progress for you and the pawn
can be e4 to reinforce his bishop to
keep it solidly in place but we play e4
black could play f5 and say hey my
bishop
is now opened up as well so i think this
game
in all likelihood will be a draw i think
they'll split the point
i'm not quite sure how white intends to
[Music]
improve the position from this point
f7 is defended
queen defends b6 you can play bishop e7
or
d8 you can play e4 and check the queen
to f3 check
i don't see what did it
could possibly do here i think it's
totally fine
so bishop e7 allows for work to d8 next
and swapping the rooks results in
immediate
quality uh rookie 6 rook d6 as well nice
and if rook d7 you play rook e7
if rookie 6 or d6 you can try to do that
rookie 6 rook d7 there still is rook d6
because you can take on f7 with check
but i can take you back because once
this rook gets to d6
it's a problem down the d file sorry i
dropped the rook on the square it means
to
play bishop e7 going for the rook swap
next move and i think we'll see a draw
green
i'm doing well thank you for asking see
you see you on the chat thanks for
everybody who's tuned in right now
we just have two games to go this one
uh and if we get a winner in the next
one then it's all over
or we go to a bullet tiebreaker and the
first to win a bullet game
wins the match so vivid is
trying to pretend like he has something
here
but it's a whole lot of nothing the
queen and the bishop doing a great job
of covering
these pawns aren't dark squares which
means the bish1c4 can't get there
okay these pieces all under attack
but so what how can you make progress
here maybe f4 at some point
doesn't look real plays it
and this queen can
probably continue to go back and forth
from e7 to c7
so
h4 takes do not take with the queen
that's how you drop a pawn and that
could be a problem even there actually
isn't so bad the nature of the opposite
color bishops should be
totally fine for black
stakes with bishop of course and now
white is up a pawn
so he's pretending hey i've got the
extra pawn all is good here
but the queen still come to e7 and maybe
into f6 that pawn moves the queen can
come into g5
yeah this is nothing hold on nothing
and i wonder if carl could start
thinking about playing for a win because
he
is well ahead in the clock and
you know if at a certain point you
realize hey i can't really lose
so why don't i play on and try to see if
i can swindle one
wouldn't be that surprised like queen f5
here
trying to get over to c2 perhaps e4 not
an easy move to play when you give up
more of the dark squares or queen f3
queen c2 check king f1 yeah it's a draw
both players know that it's a draw
but no harm in trying to
just steal a victory and no he'll trade
enough to now i think
yeah he realizes there's nothing here
and draw agreed
okay so game two now if there's a winner
the match is over if they draw their
game we get
a bullet game to decide this we're
getting
oh is he taking the bullet he car did
this on purpose he wants bullet
and you could see him trying to hold
back a smile and vidit's like oh no
oh no oh no here we go
here here's the the draw that
everybody has seen many times car did
this against magnus
if he feels like it favors him to get
rid of this game he's going to do it
and it does favor him because we get the
bullet so for vita gujarati he can enjoy
his couple rating points that he earned
from this draw but he's probably not
thrilled about entering the bullet and
you see him taking a deep breath there
stretching the neck it all comes down
to this bullet game unless they draw
in which case we get more bullet
here comes the 1-0 all right get it with
the black pieces will we see
a car go for e4 oh
what just happened
okay i guess car wasn't ready
and does vinnie get the white pieces
because he was the higher seed right
wasn't it car er evaded the three seed
and
no if it was a seven seed ah okay never
mind if it was a seven see the car was
the four seat
uh so he car gets choice that makes
sense
for some reason my head bit it was the
three c because they all tied first to
eighth place with eight and a half out
of ten
but i i was remembering incorrectly
i think i thought that mama jarv was the
two and then
it was a three but that was definitely
not the case
okay
and the game has started hit carp was e4
we have
are we getting the berlin i doubt it no
we get this
antsy delayed exchange uh spanish here
and anthony berlin and video needs to
move quickly
he needs to move well of course but he
needs to move quickly and i think that's
going to be his biggest problem
right now a car is going to use time as
a weapon and knight g5 doesn't have to
do anything this is
protect you just take back and what's
the situation
whoa hung up on did it one upon the
center
that was huge and vivid needs to fight
quickly because he is up
a clean pawn right now and he brings
queen back to e6 he wants to play f6 to
keep
his f5 no he's going aggressive here and
vin is actually ahead in the clock
wow the car blundered the e4 pawn and
now can you play e4 can you just push
that through no he doesn't do it
i'm wondering when e4 is possible but he
this g
pawn is hanging in many variations
because a5 which both
allows a4 gives his king an outlet and
now with g5 he's playing on both sides
of the board here
okay and hikaru is even on the clock
so when is e4 going to happen the queen
can be exchanged on
d5 but that fixes this pawn structure as
we enter the
late middle game stages do not take on
f4 that blunders the rook on e6
but vid is using too much time and his
position is great but i don't like his
clock management right now
e4 what's this it's nice not hanging
knight c4
what's going on here queen takes f4 is
there some kind of he takes d3 because
the back rank mate no the queen covers
on
g1 so he brings me back to c7 he just
does not
not have enough time i don't think he's
going to be really trying to save this
one but
his clock is not good no no no
no no his clock is really bad for him
yeah there's gonna be a win for a car i
feel like oh d2
what just happened there and now it's
hikaru
taking d2 next but don't take this away
because queen 61 so he takes this one
he's queen g1
that is precision by hikaru and he's
going to win
on the board he wins on the clock hikaru
nakamura takes
this speed chess championship grand prix
it was a blunder in the early stages too
did it stole a pawn
and a karu just said yeah okay i
blundered it happens
right down the center here the queen is
behind the pawn so you can't take it
back
and still won the game so what a
performance by akara nakamura
even when it looks like he's in trouble
we're going to take a our last break and
when we turn we'll bring hikaru on
get a quick interview with the speed
chess championship grand prix
winner and we are back with the
speech champion grand prix winner hikar
nakamura so i have to congratulate you
first and foremost for
qualifying for the speed chess
championship aren't you proud of
yourself
one second i apparently have to mute my
zoom
yeah okay can you hear me now i can hear
you
can you hear me
no can't hear me all right nicara
[Laughter]
way way i'm doing something wrong one
second um
yeah i think we're good now so gotcha
all right go ahead go ahead i was
congratulating you on
as a joke for qualifying for the speed
chess championship because you did win
the
speech champion grand prix like the
total series
mean just you're a monster like you just
nobody can stop you
how do you do it um you know i i mean i
think in general
uh i i think in general
um mainly what i would say is that you
just play every game do you take it one
game at a time basically
okay well how about the your decision in
the final you made that quick draw which
you've done before when you think it
optimizes your winning chances against
vidit you just said let's make a draw
and head to bullet so
that looked like a little bit of
foresight by you yeah i mean i think the
thing is is that i felt against
probably against vida and parham
specifically they're two of the best
blitz players like who i could play
against and um
and so if i have the opportunity to go
into bullet i probably should be a
bigger favorite there than i'm going to
be in
being blitz right and you certainly
proved that to be the case and when you
dropped that pawn
against a vetted there were you
concerned about the result or did you
feel like
you would be able to bounce back because
that was a pretty important pawn
objectively in the position
yeah i mean i think at that point i was
i was a little bit
um discombobulated everything was kind
of going weird cuz i tried to run an
ad and then like they started the game
right away then there was on board then
i tried to make a move and the game
started like five seconds later it was
all pretty
pretty random but i think again in
bullet more so than blitz you just you
just make moves
and i felt that um actually the game
against vedic
wasn't the one that i thought was close
i think the game against parham was the
one
um where he thought for too long there
was this critical moment in the middle
game where i think he used like 20
seconds or 15
15 to 20 seconds for two moves and that
was the game where he was up on time and
was very very complicated and i think
that one was
objectively a little bit closer and
tighter than the one against vedic so i
just kept making moves against veda and
he just couldn't keep up with the flow
yeah and obviously both of them are very
strong players
but so how do you train that like how do
you force yourself to make a move
yours just said an example of it was
complicated he was a little ahead in
time but then he spent
20 seconds so how can you force yourself
to play
a good move quickly rather than try to
find the absolute best move
i mean it's bullet just time is money as
the saying goes and um you just try to
move quickly and i i think in general
um like the one good thing about
positioning against veda especially was
that
the the way the position was i didn't
really have many things to consider i
had try to
like maneuver my knight to c4 or play
like f4 when he tries g4 h4 on the
king's side and so the fact that i
didn't really have many moves to
consider
i think really helped me in terms of
just just playing moves because there
isn't much to do
i'm down upon and much worse but you
just make moves and hopefully
your opponent isn't as fast or they make
some mistakes and indeed it uh he just
wasn't wasn't quite
fast enough at the end there yeah and he
car
throughout the speeches champions grand
prix you won five knockout brackets so
pretty impressive there did you keep
track or did you is that a
surprise to you no i didn't keep track i
mean
the thing is most of the ones that i
played in i felt were at least two of
them were very random where i got off to
a bad start i had to win like four or
five in a row at the end to to get into
the um
to get into in into the knockout so i
knew i had won quite a few i didn't
didn't really pay close attention to it
though so
um you know you just play and i i felt
it i feel like in the head-to-head
especially the format of bullet at the
end
um generally speaking i should be the
favorite against probably anybody and i
think i kind of proved that
based on how many of the knockouts i won
okay my final question for you is now we
know
four more players who are taking part in
the speed chess championship based on
their grand priest endings
and those are artemiev nuribek abutarov
parham magsudalu and hike martirosian of
well i think are you going to say our 10
meetups i'll
exclude him for the time being which of
those players has the best chance of
registering an upset in the speed chess
championship i mean
you say upset i'm not sure that i would
say our tamiya is an underdog that's why
that's why i took him out of the
equation i i would also make the
argument i'm not honestly sure that
parham is an underdog either out of
those four guys
um so yeah i guess what i would say is
in general um those first two i don't
think are gonna be
really be underdogs i think probably
notrebeck is is the one who's most
likely to cause an upset
um though out of that group of four
because i consider par
ham and artemia to be at least even if
not favorites when they who whomever
they
uh go up against the speech championship
so even if they're playing somebody like
mvl or wesley you say that
they're about level toss-up i mean i
think parham and
and um parham and vladislav the other
but they're both very strong players i
think it's close they might be slight
underdogs
but they're not going to be big
underdogs okay now that's you know some
high praise we know from our 10 yeah
he's made the semi-finals before that's
no surprise
but i guess uh by feed a classical
rating it's a different story than when
you get to the online especially
these quicker time controls so hikaru
you know gotta thank you for joining us
to interview and congratulate you once
more you are the
champion of the speeches champion grand
prix you're the reigning speeches
champion so a lot of titles to bestow
upon you and we're very appreciative of
your time
yeah thank you that's fun all right
and there you have it the final
standings of the speed chess champion
grand prix hikaru nakamura finishes
in a dominant first 137.5
points he made just as many points from
the
knockout bonus as he did from the swiss
score
and that's the difference look at that i
mean you have the players right after
him artemia ferocious
abductor and parham maxoudlu they all
scored
almost as much as hikar did as their
swiss base score
but it was where in the knockout where
hikaru was just an absolute
monster winning five of them and that's
where his bonuses came from in artemyev
he qualifies feroceae has already made
his way through
by virtue of finishing second place in
the speeches championship super swiss so
kara won that ferocious gets the second
spot and that allows heike marchi roshun
to sneak in
as the fourth qualifier from the grand
prix in addition to
nerdy back abductor and parham magsudu
and reminded everybody that there will
be more qualification spot
on the line there's one in the speed
chess
invitational which will be happening in
the near future
you should you know follow chess.com
social media to
find out when that will be follow the
news reports but it has not yet been
confirmed
as the date but 1250 first place prize
as well as the
qualification to speed chess
championship and how else could you get
the speeches championship
well most of the spots are away the top
four from the grand prix
the winner of the super swiss which
ended up being fedor save and second
nihal sarin from the jscc and that
leaves one spot up for
qualification grabs in the speedchest
championship invitational
on that note the grand prix has come to
a
conclusion it's been a really fun series
of events hikaru nakamura week in week
out
no matter who he faces no matter if he
drops an early game or not
he finds his way to the top and he is a
worthy champion we gotta give all the
credit in the world to kara nakamura
it's a bit of gujarati today
for making it such a fun fight making it
to
the bullet tiebreaker where did it stole
upon but just
couldn't keep up on the clock and so
okaru won it
and that's all from chess.com for this
speech of champion grand prix i'm grand
master robert hess until next time
keep enjoying the chest stay safe and
have a good one everybody